the queen amon is a specialty of
northern france derived from the baton
words for butter and cake the ratio for
this pastry is special
it's buttery
in fact it's 30 butter and 30 sugar
[Music]
welcome to duarnane a city with a
population of around fifteen thousand
this small coastal town has a few main
attractions including touring the
coastlines
visiting the port museum and seeing the
chapel of san michel
but that's not why we're here
we are here to meet tiri luka the man to
talk to when you want a truly authentic
queen among pastry
legend goes a baker ran out of goods in
their shop and had to whip up something
quickly
[Music]
the pastry has only a few simple
ingredients but don't let that fool you
[Music]
difficult
to
[Music]
[Music]
it's definitely a treat probably not
something you'd eat every day
is
not to have the last word but obviously
we tried it
bon appetit
and i think our face says it all and
also this spontaneous remark
oh my god that's so buttery
[Music]
10 out of 10 would recommend
whoa